[Music]
welcome guys today's lecture on rockin
games in say in the endgame and our
topic for today will be broken games and
I think that I will already cover like
the other time when I was promised
residence some rockin games and they
will be sort of part 2 4 of this
material because already I remember back
then I prepare lots of stuff but ever
since lots of things happen and I
discover some new things so I just
wanted to build up on the previous
lecture devoted to rockin games and so
let's get started so the first position
that I wanted to talk about is from game
recent game of Jeffrey Zhang against
Magnus Carlsen and this was from the
clutch chess international happened a
few days ago the Finnish few days ago
Magnus Carlsen beat Jeff in the first
round as we all know but the fight was
pretty much even
and even though Jeffrey lost first few
games even eventually it was down to
this game that basically Jeffrey was
pushing and eventually had to be
defending such endgame which happened
like this I was just moved he moves back
and after you know lots of complications
the middle game Jeffrey found three for
myself in this position where he is
actually job but he doesn't have any
real winning chance because I know if I
was just so powerful he was forced to
trade it and suddenly we got this
position where black has bone structure
but wise rook is very active and
basically just draw with correct play
however Jeffrey managed to lose this so
let's see what happened and see for
rogue f6 in g4 so far so working g7
and right now we to ask yourself
basically what's the what poses blacks
plan and what can you do to stop this
and once you ask yourself this question
basically the answer is pretty simple
only plan that black can sort of you
know how black & Windus is back to
fighting this rogue somewhere does it we
have one h1 to h4 to collect h4 point
and try to create some passed pawns on a
on the kingside but as we see whenever
this rook from a six moves bonuses will
be hanging there for once it will be
hanging whenever this route goes here
okay it's just falling and then pawn on
c4 would be actually very strong pawn
because it's actually you can advance
very quickly we see five or seven kxe
sales and so on so it's not so simple
for for black to make any progress here
having said this I think that the
simplest way to hold this position is
just to play King give free and just
wait it out and there is simply nothing
what black can do there is no way to
create any any progress here with Doc
because I broke engage six for instance
kinky for come back King there is no
which if I because h to h g5 ruby
suggesting a four doesn't really matter
king gauge seven let's say I just try to
no play some move move pieces around but
again just King a free to stay in the
same place so I tried eventually to
bring my king to d6 and keep this rook a
low c5 and then try to well activate my
robe but as we can see after route g5 in
the same defensive idea but again from
the other side like right now the rook
is attacking pollen g6 and black robe
from e6 can't be activated therefore is
just a dead draw there is no way to
improve with black and this was the
simplest path to do to draw so having
said that this was the past defense and
but
Joffrey in time pressure plate rob5 and
Magnus Americas initiative at playing
rogue f1 and
that's the big problem with the e5
because on one moment in one moment
white rook is not anymore attacking the
c6 pawn and as we know in endgame rockin
games specifically broken games active
rook is the an active active rogue as
well but also active King but especially
active rook is very very important
so here Magnus immediately activated he
looked to have one and suddenly position
is not so easy and right now still I
believe Geoffrey could have defended
this by playing p7 but again it's all
about Lucas activity right now King h6
and a rock c7 trying to finally get to
the sixth point however position is not
simple by enemies analyze Luke h1
through h6 rook takes age for kinky 5 I
can make makes a lot of sense to play
King if I because if the second goes to
f3 it would be probably very bad because
if whenever white pushes the c5 pawn
will be let's say Roxy for g4 let's say
c5 Roxy 4 will be simply winning for
black therefore therefore King a free is
too passive in this very reason why
white what should take me five lukkage
to attack in the seat upon c5 throw-in a
check probably doesn't matter
finally h4 rook c8 King h7 c6 pushing
the pawn forward and again it's a little
bit pawn race here and I feel like Black
has some chances here but in general
watch be able to hold it and for
instance row b8 trying to retreat the
rook and then try to play c7 King the 7
and this I believe should be a draw a
century 5 cc 4 + h2 Ruby 1 as I was
saying before c7 rook e8 if a now Ruby 8
is the only path to equality
after h1 square root is yet all this as
a check of engines is the best platform
for both sides and here is this finally
you draw however this position however
is this is the best path for white it
means that already after move like
rookie 5 here it means that this is
serious mistake and makes
White's task so much harder
then you should be from such position
here
therefore hereafter who give one why
this under serious pressure and again
the best way to defend it was to
activate the rook but here is Fe again
under time pressure played King before
and it's already lost okay for if King
did free just repeat a search for just
is much worse version of what we just
discussed because will be 65 black
spawns are just much faster so there is
no reason to I mean it's just it's just
lost so King c4
I mean turf like before but simply lost
pawn ending after it is this King a4 and
right now in 1455 but it's quite easy of
obviously c3 and c5 a huge re resigned
so a tragic ending for for Geoffrey but
the very instructive moment here is that
he let go for one moment - you know
what's control over what's going on
empty row g5 and suddenly after ooh give
one it's extremely difficult position at
least from practical perspective
computers of course save it quite easily
by playing this the lines that suggested
with rookie 757 but anyway here after
rookie 5 rook f1 Black has very big
chances and for for win and enjoy free
merely made a mistake by blinking before
so this is the first person to talk
about second one will be from and this
is actually interesting because the
second position it's very similar that I
want to talk about is the first similar
the game that I play against a barrage
of 2013 and this is the game I shot
already last time and I'll just quickly
do a small recap on this game because
here after let's say the interesting
disposition
right so this is basically pretty much
draw which endgame seemingly and of
course h5 is the best defense and
I think I will repeat as again the best
attempt for white to create any winning
chances or less the practical winning
chances is to play let's say here h4 and
try to get to play at some point g4 and
trade war spawns and again try to trade
h4 h4 for Japan and this and if if white
can have any chances for a real transfer
it should be there at least practical of
course it's still draw of correct play
but forest for instance I managed to
lose this game so there are some
difficulties however in this game this
is game by the way picot Kasparov from
2004 mere 2000 and the game happened f4
so I don't think that this is actually
the best attempt for white to win this
however in this game
pig had managed to beat curry and he I
mean you it was impressive how he did
but the there another thing that's kind
of impressed about this game is what
kind of ideas in seemingly draw it end
game like this there still exist so
let's have a look and game happen g6 and
this is obviously the correct setup in 5
roopd free King age free and Kasparov
played rookie free king gauge for so far
so good King g7 King is perfectly placed
on g7 and King g5 so basically what
tried to create this pawn chain with the
phones from h2 through g3 at 45 and then
bring the King Friedrich hood to 84 and
n g5 the schema is definitely very
active and if it could of course would
be ideally placed on f6 however black
skin is obviously plays well on g7 and
it's no not easy task for for watcing to
get any further
therefore in here but by this position
Kasparov made a losing mistake and this
is extremely instructive I believe
because such move is probably one of the
most expected moves to be played here in
this position and his movies here is
rupee one seemingly this move is like
it's okay like you know the boy didn't
create any first Ruben you one is let's
say you normally placed stops all kind
of moves like e6000 five there is no any
breakthrough here and if let's say this
route go somewhere then we can go to the
e to file and I talk white pawns what
hold h2o let's see what goes h3 then
rookie free and there is some counter
play so seemingly this is a very valid
you know defensive setup however it is
not and will still moment why and the
best defense here is rook a free the
best defense is rook a free and this is
the idea behind this move is to play
after Roxy seven to play rook a5
basically we need to pin this pawn and
the King in order to on the fifth rank
and prevent all kind of a six and f5
through the having by having this pawn
on the zircon on the fifth string and
this is basically nearly immediate draw
there is no way to improve this position
with with with white so in the game
happened rook e1 and we'll see in a
moment example what happened and like
what could have happened in similar game
and I will discuss in a moment
there was game arriving sorry Michael
Adams versus Aravind in 2019 and belief
and the would seize the moment
were arriving present that very good
defensive setup so will seize the moment
but see why let's see first white rook
e1 loses and the thing is that right now
after rock c7 winning move black is
simply in sort of a tux funk and the
white has very powerful threat or threat
of the playing cookie seven in Ruby
seven and then after Ruby seven of
playing
f5
and if what can get this basically all
that suddenly all the post structure for
black will fall apart and there is no
way to to you know to really stop this
right now so there are basically several
moves let's say if Rudy free just comes
back
Ruby seven and nothing really changes
and suddenly next move is a five and
it's game over if Rudy took happens this
would happen in the game again
rookie seven happens f5 is coming and
there is no way basically to stop this
let's say if the game if if Ruby one for
instance suddenly is six is of course f5
or EC czar to basically winning threats
here so if it's X takes takes and
suddenly after h3 what is winning by
force disposition if king of seven King
age six and King of six and suddenly now
g4 and this is just game over because
with this point endgame is winning if
king of surrender is g5 apologetics is
falling if gh4 is sorry h4 then g5 king
at five Eastern basically everything is
forced right now there is no any other
move skin to hd6 if I've trying to get
the pawn at the e1 queen king of 6e for
g6 III g7e to g8 Queen e1 Queen Queen g4
can give frequency six trading the
Queen's and King g5 you have to engage
for King a freaking g5 and why wins
basically everything is just forced as I
checked there is no any room for
improvement from neither of the sides
there is no there are no alternatives
everything is just forced and this leads
to such such such win for white there is
nothing better for both colors so for
both sides so here if rook e1 this is
the problem if it does six wins
f5 is also possible but it is just waste
on the spot and after okay to is what
happened the game ran out the other idea
f5 she takes a five and right now is six
and basically the thing is that if we've
got six immediately there is a possible
checker okay
five and our king is first you know to
go go back and after this to begin f6
move and suddenly it's still a draw so
it's not so easy here therefore we did
this the reason we played first of five
to cover the fifth string and now play
is sixth and we are just collecting
pollen f7 and that's game over just how
the game ended h4 roof days of seven
kingi gate and king of six guards part
of resigned just simply those position
there is simply nothing to discuss here
it's just just winning
however there I analyze in this I was
really cursed about it is it already
like so bad after Ruby one is restore
but after seven did you know it's simply
lost and then I discovered that there
could be some interesting idea of rookie
four and the idea is that of course a
five right now isn't possible and if
because if a five dollar widget for
checkmate an Iraqi seven the suddenly
look a four and as you can see in this
position of the rookie to here rookie
seven rook a to right now at five wins
but if the same position like this
position is not only two but on a four
so we'll move there one in a moment this
position after f5 there is Ruby for
checkmate so this it would be still a
draw if let's say rookie for if dr. Ruby
for and right now rook building or
meeting group is seven move rook a for
it suddenly stood a draw because is
extruded five is the same defensive idea
and a five is impossible and it without
it
we were black rook goes to a five and a
draw so what can Y do and here I found
astonishing resource which is I know
it's is extremely hard to find over the
board and I kind of like to understand
why but Brooke a7 sorry okay seven
rugae seven move simply put black in
tubes Fung there is no broken if roc-roc
only four was perfectly placed
and it was basically stopping whites
whites counter whites attack White's
attacking ideas connect with a six and A
five
but right now if this move rook moves
from afar suddenly the ideas of f5 and
ecigs
will be available and but we might ask
what happens let's have to look before
let's say e six still we can give a
check and you know it's still like not
not a big deal or if a fire chief or
still seemingly it's quite okay so right
now g4 g4 is a powerful powerful move
and the idea is again to play at some
point f5 and to cover g4 square that
black rook and the can't play rock g4 so
after g4 h to h g4 f5 right now and
after this is six and this is again
winning four why because we take on f7
and King comes to f6 and it's politics
is just simply too powerful to be
stopped with the support of the rukon
and King Khan on f6 white is simply
winning Ruby six rook takes of seven
King g8 and King f6 for instance if a
Ford tries to trying to get activated
some pawns and maybe you know push them
forward rubgy seven and we can just take
this and this is just game over
so after rookie for inspiration with
seven rookie for rook h7 is amazing
resource here for for white and it leads
to
nicely winning endgame here so but this
was the last trick basically so if you
let's say rookie for another look a
seven but rookie seven with the same
idea or suddenly okay four doesn't lead
anywhere it's simply a draw so
having said that let's let's let's move
to the next game that I want to talk
about and the next game what I'm gonna
talk about is Adams versus Aravind and
as we can see the end game is very very
similar and in here five King f8 f 4
King g7 rugae - Ruby freakin h3 as you
guys can see is exactly the same type of
endgame but right now Aravind defended
very nicely and he let's see how because
I have nothing to add to his to his
defense right now
Ruby 5 is a little bit more accurate
because just placing the group and a 5th
rank is just aminute draw but he player
would be 7 which is also good every wave
3 Roxy 7h3 Roxy 5 just right now placing
the rook on a 5th rank g4 takes takes
rook c5 and if Ruby 7 just broke a 5 and
this is the one of the most important
positions here there is no way for for
white to improve in this position
because right now after let's say f5
black has very nice tactical idea of
taking rook takes e5 the route 85 f6
king of 4f takes e5 everything is
beginning it may be simplified King
takes the five King f7 is just that draw
because of the Opposition King the sake
into [ __ ] 7 obviously if g5 draw so
this is very important idea to remember
our chopped wood once again in this
position to place the roof on a fifth
rank and always whenever this happens
ruby 7 just rook stays on the 5th rank
and if F 5 happens then the rook takes a
5-story f5 route xe5 route 85 and f6 and
this is just came over so here
yes so this basically all for for for
this line if sorry for for this endgame
because this is just very simple but you
know if Cara Casper didn't manage to
save this it means that don't without
tricks so therefore is important to know
even such simple end games how to how to
defend in them so let's go to the next
one
and the next one would be this position
from game Aronian versus Nakamura and is
from Canada's tournament from Moscow
2016 and in this position I mean
basically the end game the terminal game
11 Iranian was pressing for a win he had
very nice position although the opening
and finally he found himself players
armed themselves in this end game were
certainly why his big advantage the
question whether it's sufficient to win
so let's evaluate this like in like why
I mean like why why this better
definitely because of the activity of
pieces first of all rock white rook is
much more active than black group
another thing King is a little bit act
more active than black King and right
now also the post structure even though
it seems like white has destroyed pawn
structure because of the pose of 43 f2
and with either a pawn on h4 it is still
white has been pawn structure because it
is white right now to play and what can
playing with c4 and we've moved with
Musa four pawns b6 and c5 are blocked
and whenever a black will try to play b5
c5 and F four points will be simply weak
and on top of this white can play move
like e4 e5 maybe and try to maybe make
brave a pawn breakthrough with f5 that's
why I think that Y has really really
good choices to win this and they came
happen King g7e for very good and the
idea is to play e5 and in this position
the best defense was rook is 7 and the
idea of row b7 is to place in Group B 7
+ b5 trying to simplify the position and
let's say if I've Ruby 7 where they have
idea b5 in Rakhine games especially when
there when you are defending you should
try to exchange as many important as
possible
in order to simplify the position and
try to even if or even if you have to
give the pawn or something usually when
there are less pieces on the board there
are some drawing chances and this is the
perfect example for this because after
Ruby seven a black tries to play b5 and
tries to simplify the position and
eventually try to hope to defend for
versus free it was just a little bit
different than the four versus free
which we discussed in two previous games
casper-peak er Kasparov and Adams
Aravind so here analyze actually quite a
lot and I thought okay I just just to
show Rudi's if ruby six let's say B 5 CJ
Andrew k 6 the position is getting
simplified after take stake through
before Andrew k 5 white with the Point C
5 that's true but it's not easy to make
progress here with white because first
of all I mean there are many moves which
can happen but let's say H if H 5 root
xt5 rugae 4 and pollinate 2 is basically
gone and so is pawns before but again
black task is to defend and for to
defend it we need to eliminate as I mean
like exchange as many points as possible
and try to simplify the position so this
is the major defensive idea here for
black if black decides to play some
moves like f5 and the here position gets
pretty sharp but still with correct
defense at least we're all as it takes
King 1/4 f6 again we try to simplify the
position as much as possible
why doesn't want to simplify the
position but again we just take f3
otherwise we just you know there is like
we take on f2 and it's simple it's a
simple draw after a free roogie - ketta
is a 5
roogie 5 it's everything go ball goes by
force it's not still on is the endgame
but it it is just a draw
so after takes takes King takes e5 c3
King the six c2 e
seven c128 Queen Queen f3 there is no
way neither side can the ears I can win
this with you know I mean it's just
wrong
so this was the best defense if ruby
seven rugby seven so if the Rudy six be
five in this we discussed is basically
very lucky at draw so what why what else
can we do and the best
I thought attempt for why to create any
sort of chances is to play h5 tried to
break while blacks bone structure here
on the on the kingside in order to after
GT x h5 play f5 and half was to postpone
it's not postponed by two strong tones
on f5 and only five and f5 and try to
bring the king forward and you know
maybe create a passed pawn using both be
5 and F 5 points so this is this was
actually better chance
however after b5 takes takes rook d7 and
the idea is of course is six I feel like
black has enough counter play again to
make a draw after C for kinky for and h4
suddenly because of this extra pawn on
eight file that can create more counter
play by pushing this pawn forward
let's say e6 h3 ruk f7 King g8 rook f6c
free suddenly it's not easy to stop
postpones
without kind of giving up the initiative
so give King the free king with redness
as active on defense it was only for
rook c5 King c2 and let's say rookie
five I don't see to be honest how white
can really improve here because h2 is
coming but pawns words are collapsing
that's also Ruby - rogue f2 coming in
possibly King g7 also it could be
annoying
move to to face I don't think there is
enough basically
you know there is you know enough for
you know for what to play for because
the king is on to send is so passive and
black so active on which free creates
more than enough counter play and if
like white group decides to stop with
this pawn age free to give up
pawns very likely a five and a six so we
very lucky it just draw so this was the
best defense Ruby seven and by some
reason here I don't know exactly why but
he can play rook e8 and maybe it was
just kind of like sort of he I don't
know what happened but Ruby eight is a
little bit weird because the same idea
as rookie seven will be seven but Ruben
is is much worse place because on the
because right now white rook can jump
into seventh rank and there are all the
time issues with this ePHI ecigs idea so
let's see what happened the game if I've
Ruby eight and as I was saying right now
Ruby seven and if we look at this
position earlier with the rook is seven
and if I group be seven Ruby's place
right now on b7 and Polly this position
is on b8 and gives Y additional option
of Ruby seven and right now it says it's
coming in is a big threat and white
gains essential ten P in creating the
attack right now or like you know
developing the initiative on the
kingside kink f8 f5 which takes a five
King at four
yeah so I'll just make a note here f5 is
typical idea obviously try to you know
sacrifice temporarily upon but instead
but after takes King a for King taste of
five and ideally King f6 King would be
very active so this is the very good
technique by LaVon b5 takes rook takes
d5 context of five and this is pretty
much very important position right now
in general I feel like position is maybe
still called Abu I analyzed a lot but
couldn't get to the sort of final kind
of like final conclusion whether it's
lost or is not lost
definitely what create Bob white has
lots of chances to win this and blacks
define defensive stats
extremely hard just but because just
look like the skin gonna fire is so
active King f6 is very often a big
threat and if the the poem from f2 can
join let's say F 4 and then King can go
somewhere and then f5 the suddenly most
pawns will create lots of tactical ideas
for white and just the fact that there
are still those pawns on the Queen side
it doesn't make a blacks task any easier
so right now I will just quickly show
what happened in the game a3 and this is
horrible mistake because right now after
this move black is simply lost
immediately and by some reason I don't
know exactly why but never one didn't do
it because he played a for we just
returning simply the favor right now
after King of six the most logical move
roopd ism made mating fret of many one
Ruby six choice Ruby six and this is
just game over black cannot trade maybe
this is what he missed or something
that's a this is this and King B 5 and
this is Bob maybe this will both players
missed after King g5 I feel like this
just came over because King D 5 sorry
Kim D 1785 and we collect the c5 pawn
and if let's say uh no Queen d7 King
defy c4 can you take c4 King d6 we are
just collecting this pawn and with the
say King defy working f3 with the extra
pawn we just kind of on the side we can
deflect backing to this point we can
deflect black into this point and we can
of course run away around with our King
to the Queen King sighs it just came
over so I don't understand what happened
you read maybe it was kind of like time
pressure or something I'm not sure but
after here King f6 Ruby 6 it is just
winning immediately for for white so
after Ruby 8 for Luke CA let's say F 5 C
4 and finally rook d7 as I was saying if
white King can move let's say ideally
forward to have 6
and then white bones joins a four with a
four and a five and black group goes to
d7 right now
Krueger 7 is you know winning if we can
play and you've worked these six then
just each six is covering the six Frank
and this point six is much faster
because we aren't only trying to promote
the in the pawn on e6 but they also
trying to mate with rookie yet or maybe
if rooks either we can consider drug
agent 700-page ID for instance also look
f7 should be winning
I mean it's simply winning position for
for white so therefore I don't if you
see free rook f7 ii yet Ruby g7 ii give
a each six is very similar just east
avenue g8 just came over so having said
that I don't really understand I know
what happened here for two Volvos super
grandmasters that know like that he car
blunder king of six and eleven didn't
play King s it's just hard to understand
right now but you know usually when you
can take King f6 and practically right
now if all works you should just do it
so anyway in the game happened f4 and
we'll get there in a moment
I actually know that was actually
discuss here after F because every cover
in the game that's why a3 is a mistake
let's discuss first one was the best
trend and I think that the best defense
were here was kinky eight we took his
rook out from this seven that first of
all whenever King goes to have six the
Rose there is never rub d6 so let's save
rook c7 I feel a father was the best
chance black tries to counter play rugby
to attacking both pawns a to and f2 if a
for suddenly a free makes sense trying
to take on a two and push pull a upon us
as far as possible and the thing is
right after your king of six you could
see that earlier with the King on a
final 27 there was Ruby sixth after b6
there was Ruby six always right now it's
not possible because Ruby's on c7
that's why if King g7 let's say Ruby six
the Rope dries the kink out of the
center and goes to a Kinkos 2h7
androgogy for and still there are lots
of chances for a white but I feel like
eventually black has some chances to
hold this however is by not is by enemy
is not so easy let's say F 5 c4 f 6 H 5
the rookie 7 checking afraid and the
question whether white has hear anything
let's hear anything better than Ruby 7
and just go some of the rook to be
honest I don't know I try to find but
like I feels to me that black I didn't
have defensive resources because porn h4
is also hanging pawns e4 is still it's
still there and this possibly is
possible that if the route goes from c7
somewhere that the c3 pawn will just go
forward and both importantly as I said
pwnage first hang so if the spawn is
lost this H 5.10 go forward as well and
such bad King Khan h7 for white I'm not
sure whether white has enough resources
to twin this that's why I feel I think
that the best defense here was all King
f6 but rook takes d5 just eliminate this
pawn root X a to Andrew gave 5 bring
this room behind the pond we just
normally to be called yeah and right now
the phrase obviously King f6 and a5
because if we can get this normally we
should be winning with white here but
it's again not so easy because rook h2
and right now for king of 6 was the most
logical move and rook F 2 and after a 5
a 2 and the question is whether here
white can win and to be honest I found
some type some ideas here for a white
but I'm not entirely sure whether there
are enough you know chances to win this
because the pollinate 2 is so advanced
and creates enough counter play for
black because our rook our I mean white
rook is has to you know take care of
basically this point if a 2 so I
basically analyze here many things but I
thought that this this and h5 is the
like principled way to fight for
advantage here and the idea is that here
black is in sort of cooked funk because
the rope has to be defending somehow
this pollinate to so it can go anywhere
and the spawn Ruben f2 also has to be at
a component of five because if white can
take context of seven will without
giving this f5 upon white will be simply
winning so if this is the case black has
to move the king
so after king c6 right now my fault is
six is the best move and after this
context is six and trying to push this
pawn forward f6 and f7 so on however
King basurin is everything nearly all by
force Roque free and right now basically
amazing I have any defensive resource
here by by black rook c2 it's completely
like computer chess right now ideas
through basics obviously but you know
such moves are you know over the board
are you know especially in time trouble
are hard to find so I mean on top of
this there's its analysis so analyzed
and you know perfectly black probably
can hold but in real game I'm not
entirely convinced whether white can
whether black can actually hold would be
able to hold this that's why I feel like
Y has lots of us the winning chances
seeking of semi-automatic rooks seven
check in 66 and if six Lucases that's
the entire point of rock c2 and then try
to bring the route to the sixth rank
with track and then play route k-6 try
to push this pawn forward and right now
for the repeat x86 f7 a one Queen f8
Queen and we will get to this and game
we just basically another story you know
which is I mean this endgame is
terrifically drawn but you know in real
game the player playing with black
pieces can make a drug here is
completely different story because you
know there are lots of ideas for white
to transparent Wyck the opponent
and it's not from practical perspective
easy to defend it
even though objectively of course it is
a draw and table bicycle confirm that
but you know it's not always all the
time about table bases and you know
what's theoretically winning or drawing
but what about what about is more about
theoretical I mean pride sort of
practical problems you can actually post
your opponent and here certainly there's
some problems to resolve with black
right so it's not so easy it's not sweet
even though this was the king he was the
best defense but you know if King yet
was the best defense here and leads to
such crazy position with such crazy line
it means that very likely practically
position is nearly lost for for black in
my opinion obviously so after Giga five
he car played a three which is very very
bad mistake of course can give six right
now wins as I was mentioning earlier
however eleven played a four
we just sort of you know returning the
favor I don't understand
as I was saying what happened that he
played have four but this you know right
now group before through before it's not
easy anymore to in this because King of
six rotates at four so eleven played
Roque 7c4
Luke takes a three collecting the point
but right now rugby to and again a black
you know black has enough counter play
because it is pretty much very hard to
protect a safety spoon on a two as both
pawns a twenty four very likely would be
traded
let's say if you take if you take say -
if course if that was to play right now
so I've and if most pawns are traded
very likely the rising position is just
drawn so Luca is six it happened in the
game a King g7 and right now I feel like
this is the most important position from
this game this is so important right now
because I think this was kind of missed
by commentators maybe I'm wrong
I'm wrong but like simply here the
position is still extremely difficult
for white sorry for black and black even
though it seems like you know this just
see free c2 is in our next moves and
this a two point will be traded for c4
pawn and this what happened again I
would put you sure will happen next two
moves in the game and you know this is
what happened
pollen a is gone and see points also
gone and in this position it is you know
of course huge achievement by black and
the position normally the game should be
drawn here and we'll will let's see
maybe at first what happen in the game
and we'll get back to this moment to
this moment what what could have done
differently so let's see the game's
first see favor get 72 Roxy Roxy seven
room before I mean a 500k for text to
route 85 and right now the game went
down in this position so as we see this
is very similar position to the position
we discussed earlier in the games of
Pickett Kasparov and Adams Aravind is
the differences that there are no G
pawns here apart form is pretty much the
same but yeah this creates some some
chances for a while but with correct
defense black should easily defended a
rooks e7 King f8 obviously we can't
allow ecigs this is one of the main
ideas here so we can't allow this with
black king afraid if king of six rupees
six obviously Ruby seven okay four
points a persona for porn defrayed
maneuvering around bringing peace you
know here and there up before books see
one rupee for if King III for if if I
wanted to get to h6 point it's not so
easy because after here suddenly wide
black Steven willingly given this point
in order to activate the scheme to a5
would basically just drawn position
there is no way what could improve here
if rook before which happened the game
just king of it back route b6 King g7
protecting the pawn rugby 7 again just
back
no no real progress for k1 or opt for
okay to room
and finally in this position
LaVon managed to trick he ha hikaru
because as we have seen several times on
several occasions earlier he played hero
before let's say hero b7 King evade and
here if that's a king of six there will
be of course Roxy six right
but in hero b8 finally moved to d4 and
ran a paper route e7 so right now if
King f8 there is king f6 obviously and
suddenly after work f6 and rookie six
there is route d6 and the game is over
this is how LaVon won this the game is
over the King got to have six points
going to a5 king can be kicked out from
f6 and it's simply simply mean and so
let's see how the game finished Ruka 8
h5 king j f5 roopd 8 root d7 rook b6
King g7 suddenly you know the king you
know enters the seventh rank and it's
all basically you know just winning
because e cigs is coming in and pawns
basically prone to the Queen and came
over so here actually he can resign with
the view of e6 however let's move let's
move back and here King f8 happened but
still I believe that there were still
enough drink just as they have to do get
to there is not know it is not easy for
for white to make any progress still
even in this position let's say if right
now Ruby 7 we go simply rotate to and 6
rugae 5 check always this at the idea of
check on a 5th rank to the king and keep
driving in backwards you know to let say
for Frank it's very important the
defensive idea in Volvo starboard
positions if h5 we can just wait 7 Ruby
- we just wait and rugae - if when every
six does ok 5 check and here King f8
let's say if King of 6 rugae 6 and
the draw no no no any you know progress
is available basically but I black
should be able to hold it so this is how
11 manage trick
hikaru because hippo carp licking
awaking offices with winning position
however okie to was still holding a draw
however but anyway this this endgame
should be generally drawn so if white
sorry if black manages to trade those
pawns a and C then this for sorry three
versus two on the on one side even
though about G file J pawns it should be
drawn so in here let's let's move back
few moves in the endgame and see what
what because this basically the critical
position in this position if those bones
are still there so white should look for
the sort of attempt to look for
something that involves both pawn still
on the board and not and not to try to
not to trade them because if they're on
the board it means that wife has more
winning chances here because without
them it's basically pretty
straightforward draw draw as we have
seen like in the analysis that I just
showed so here I believe that the best
if but attacking idea here for what is
to play rook a7 and what what was going
on the idea is to play six of course so
black has to defend some of from this
let's say if c5 happens is six will be
five kinky for rook c5 is also possible
route text f7 King g8 and right now very
strong move rook f6 of course is
computer analysis maybe it's overboard
very hard to find it but like that's the
entire point of you know this lecture
and kind of like trying to understand
what are the ideas and kind of like why
rook and games are sort of so insane
I can put it like this because there are
lots of ideas for both sides and it's
it's from learning perspective it's it's
just it's just just great
so rook f6 rook c7 and the idea is if c2
if I'm not mistaken just seven and after
rook c8 there's ideas Roxy six is a
beautiful idea that basically stopping
the spawn is stopping the C pawn by you
know with this tactical you know
resource that blood White has so c2 is
not possible there therefore black has
to play rook c7 and right now White has
two options and to be honest I'm not
sure which one is the better one I will
show both because it just just really
really you know confusing to analyze
this and I say one is king defeat and
second one is rookie g6 so the idea of
king defeat but you start this one with
the king of King III C 2 and e 7 and if
rook takes is 7 King takes C 2 and this
should be winning because there are two
extra pawns forward should and if CC one
Queen EA twin but black doesn't have to
promote to the Queen
there is also possibility to promote to
the night C one night and this is a very
funny line but I believe that after King
D 2 King text 1 like what the silk opens
up but it's not easy to right now to win
this because of the activity of black
route that there is right now let's
taking g7 I look at five King g6 let's
say rook 2 goes to e5 and Ruby c7 King
bee - it's very important there was C
one night because if this was same
position of King on c2 the key would go
to say to be free and we'll cover the
for Frank but right after can be to Roxy
for it's basically but only moves
basically but it works it's just that's
why I said to show this game because
none of this has been asked to at least
to the best of my knowledge has been
explored so far and I just want to share
some
new light on this especially I'm giving
a chance you know during the you know
talking about end games in this lecture
talking of six Ruby five loop takes the
four and the question is whether white
can win this and personally I don't
think that white has any realistic
chance of winning this with core
difference by black let's say King be
free or Jeffrey came before just King g7
and I asked your be six because if I
fall very likely the King is just you
know coming in and it's also possible to
start with Group A for for instance so
it's not so easy to you know my game
progress it would be six trying to hit
on H six point we just throw in more
checks
Ruby five ok 5 would be 5 Ruby f4 and if
a for just King comes into the kinks so
the Queen side is just not easy to make
any further progress with with white so
I just think that this is this should be
this should be somehow drawn here
but anyway it's extremely difficult and
in like real game this would be while we
have lots of lots of attempts to you
know I'll play the opponent other
possibilities route g6 King f8 group g1
and try to stop the spawn of the rook
but after oopsie for King f5 let's say
c1 3 c1 c2 rooks one King Seven I also
don't really see what white could do
here next like because blacks rook is so
active in pole and why our and point C 2
is basically forcing what I would look
to be so passive and c1 black should
have normally enough resources to to
make a drug here so Luke a7 regressive
idea is this was by far the most testing
one even though there are definitely
good choices for black to say save this
Ruby 7 creates a lot of practical
problems that black would have to still
resolve and like as we discussed in this
line it's not easy to you know figure
out what to do here with with by the 7
is on easy move also to play is
easy to blunder this move for instance
it's very easy to blunder
so route 7 would be have to be played
and there right now even this kingi free
and e7c one night on sending that see
one actually not makes a lot of
difference in this endgame that this is
actually very likely drawn it's also not
an easy task so having said that other
possibility is king so series one move
king evades other possibility and right
now one very very important idea that I
really wanted to show is to play here
King before and the idea is also I don't
think was mentioned anywhere ideas to
play simply f5 if because if we can get
power point left five then point to f6
there also there will be always some
mating nets and some tactical ideas for
for for white that's why let's save if
safe
white black has to move in a ruby 2 or C
3 and if ruby 2 Queen the four gauge to
trying to basically attack at the age
four point but right now after a four
rook takes age for kinky for while he's
extremely big winning chances for
instance if rook h1 is already lost
because a5 rugae won a 6 H 5 + f5 and
white points are just much faster
h4 f6 as I was saying that lots of
tactical is connective ok 8 for now King
g8 looka 8th King h7 and King the form
of idea of ethics and f7 because
immediate run into rook e1
well if you play this first we attack on
c4 black is forced to do something about
it and I mean major ideas of course to
play a six right now and this is just
came over but if rook e1 happens in a 7
and the other pawn is promoting so
basically there is no way to stop both
pawns
so the white is winning and therefore in
this position the best defense the rook
h2 which I have which I still have
problems one thing why it makes such a
huge difference
rook c7 rugae - to be honest I not not
sure why you know a 7s r a5 it doesn't
really work but you know sometimes
engines make such weird so I mean such a
huge difference when you look at the
engine
so let's see if a five let's say okay -
I I think so at least a six see free I
think it has to do with a fight that
policy - is protected which is kind of
weird - you know if you think about it
but like I guess it works
so if Ruby seven let's say rugae - or
even h5 there there are still some
chances for white because we've got an
extra pawn and it's black but but but
like I still have some chances because
you know there's h po h postponed and
there are still some chances however the
bear defense is probably see free
because this is extremely tricky it's
like even in this position if we can
just get c4 pawn just from principle
point of view if you can get c4 pawn
will have egg passport a file on the
queenside
and still we have this powerful pawn
shine at 45 so there are definitely good
chances provide the best defense
probably c3 but after very strong of a3
the idea is again to sort of I mean
first of all idea c7 and we have to pawn
a free there has never in check on
before so like for instance after a for
there could be a problem with move like
this or a root before this rook c4 there
could be some issues with this therefore
it's very important to play a three in
or not to allow this and after okay too
King f5 because if f5 suddenly rook h2
could save the game but this is
extremely difficult to figure out over
the board
rook a to I remember was the only move
and I feel like in general White has
very very good winning chances here
let's say if you see to the rock c7 just
probably ways because right now at 5 ft
6 again it's coming in here we can play
king b5 ok free just take it and the
difference with this position relative
to the pond with the king called f5 and
pollen f4 is it here our pond is already
on f5 and we can always play f6 by can
create some tactical ideas around black
King and by promoting you know pipe
making a pawn break with f6 or or ecigs
so definitely here after Luke a 7 I'm
not claiming that white is winning but
why has extremely big chances of winning
the game at least from practical
perspective because are so many first
for black and black has to be extremely
cautious here and yeah so this was the
best chance and but just if one table if
we would wrap it up
Luke a7 is the best move because it
creates some threats it doesn't kind of
give room for black to I know I kind of
just to play simply C 3 C 2 and just you
know make a draw like this there are
still lots of ideas here for for black
that black has to be sorry for white the
black has to be careful about because
right now is 6 is a big threat and it
has to be immediately sort of sort of
dealt with the say King f8 or C free if
king of red king before and a 5 f6 is
very powerful idea that you know over
the board could just win instantly so
yeah I think this is pretty much all for
this game and this pretty much all what
I have what I wanted to cover today for
about the weekend games even though I
analyzed a lot I didn't still fully and
like get the total conclusion about it
and game is winning or not but anyway
there are so many ideas here and and
both for wide and for black to try to
defend it
that I was thinking that is really wore
fit to show this game because it just so
shows how we have reached our roof and
games and just in general as a game so
yeah that's all I have for today and see
you next next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]